this is 2015 the century has gone since
general relativity was first introduced
and I thought it'd be worth just talking
a little bit about how Einstein was
really quite resistant to the idea that
the universe is expanding and he worked
very hard to stop it it ultimately
failed and he ultimately accepted that
it failed but it's quite interesting to
see the effort he put in to actually
make the universe static and then the
consequence of that today and the term
that he introduced to make the universe
static looks like it it's around today
and driving the acceleration of the
universe which is a kind of it I really
get any quieter and provide I don't you
know around 1915 if you what was
astronomy telling us well astronomy
you'd look out in the night sky
and you'd see night after night the
Stars and you might see the Andromeda
with your are kind of understandably to
me it seems that Einstein thought the
universe was static he also had reasons
for wanting it to be static he believed
the universe on large scales had to be
homogeneous and isotropic it kind of it
looked the same every in all directions
and we were in no special place in the
universe Albert Einstein wasn't a
caveman like he did up at the stars and
think there were little points of light
he saw beyond skin deep so surely he
didn't look up at the nice guy I think I
has to always be the same but people
didn't know what the universe looked
like beyond our Milky Way why would you
have the universe expanding if you don't
see it if you don't see any evidence of
it in fact his beautiful equations it
must have been a nightmare for him when
he began to look at them and other
people quickly began to look at them in
1915 it must have been a nightmare for
him when he discovered actually he can't
have it static he'd written it down it
just would not stay a static what do the
equations do the left-hand side of the
equations will relate the curvature of
space and to the matter content of the
universe and so you have you have this
situation where the two are
intrinsically connected so that if the
matter evolves it will affect the
curvature of the space-time in which
it's evolving
as the curvature of space-time evolves
it actually determines the trajectory
that the matter takes so let me draw two
galaxies so here's two galaxies okay I'm
going to give them a separation and to
make life simple this is this should be
a of T right so a is known as the scale
factor and it tells me about the the
rate at which the space-time is about is
evolving right and it's this that
Einstein didn't want to evolve because
he didn't think that this there was any
movement in the space-time itself he
just thought that the the universe was
nice and static so if you've got a of T
then just let me let's just define a
couple of terms for us if I call it a
dot the rate of change of a let me call
it a velocity type term right it's
telling me about how this scale factor
is changing the time that's how does
distance change with time that's a
velocity and if I introduce an a double
dot then that's like the acceleration
term okay that's telling me how the rate
of change of the velocity
what would a static universe mean a
static universe would be one that where
a is a constant a dot would equal a
double dot which would equal zero
there'd be no acceleration because if
there was acceleration it would generate
a velocity so why does this not work why
did Einstein realize this in fact think
the metric pointed out it wasn't going
to work there are two major equations
that you can write down from main
Stein's
a theory of relativity that apply to
cosmology to really needs equation so
I'll write down the the first the first
of these which is useful is called the
acceleration equation so it tells me how
a double dot divided by a and it's given
in terms of funnily enough Newton's
constant so there's four pi gigi is
Newton's constant over three and then it
has these two contributions it's got a
term which I'll call Rho and then it has
another term which I'll call P and in
fact C squared is the speed of light
okay Rho is the density of matter the
energy density of matter so any matter
in the universe will contribute some
energy density Rho so as long as the
universe has got matter in there then
Rho is nonzero P is the pressure of that
and further for the a universe made up
of particles like you and I that are not
moving very rapidly if you just think
about how particles you know pressure is
the force per unit area
these particles hardly do anything so
the pressures effectively zero but the
key thing is Rho is nonzero so if I have
a universe with matter then it tells me
that Rho is not equal to zero and that
then immediately tells me because it
means to let the right-hand side of here
is nonzero so a double dot is not equal
to zero
and Einstein's had it the universe is
going to evolve when I Stan was looking
at this
he knew the universe was mainly made up
of matter you know you could look at the
Stars
we knew matter was dominating so it's
the leading term here in fact radiation
can only add to this you'll just make it
even worse so it was clear that the the
universe had this had this problem it
seems as if it was going to evolve and
so what Einstein did was he real he
decided that there was another term
where he knew there was another term
which he he hadn't been adding to his
equations but if he added them to his
equations he could actually sort this
issue out but it isn't this a bit like
if I always want Brazil to win games of
soccer and they lose three nil I just
invented u-turn where Brazil always get
an extra four goals right at the game as
long as your new term was consistent
with what your original rules were right
that's the key thing he his this term is
going to add this cosmological constant
term is perfectly consistent with the
underlying principles that he had which
had that developed developed into
general relativity he didn't just take a
number on the you know known okay and
let's put - April I know I think he just
thought for reasons which I mean I don't
know they presumed that it wasn't their
religion when he was written originally
thinking how it was zero for some reason
in fact he probably have no right to
think that he probably should be
thinking all the time why don't I
include it so he did include it actually
it affects this equation but I'll do
that in a second let me write down the
second equation which is known as the
Freedman equation and that tells me
about the house of Allah
evolves okay so this is called the
Hubble parameter by the way that a dot
over a so this is actually given by the
following it's given by that energy
density again with Newton's constant in
there and then I can add in a new term
which is this most this is my
cosmological constant lambda these
factors of three are just to make life
simpler and then there is another term
which is going to be important and this
tells me about the curvature of my
universe this is the a by the way this
this scale factor okay this is known as
the Friedman equation there are three
terms this is my energy density the of
them of the matter that I'm thinking
about this is my cosmological constant
term lambda is a constant and this term
K represents the curvature of the
special curvature of the universe
because it turned out there are three
possibilities that that are consistent
with Einstein's original idea that the
universe is homogeneous and isotropic
one is if K is positive and that's known
as a closed universe so the universe is
finite in special extent it grows to a
big to fixed size and then collapses
again the second which is what it looks
like the universe looks like is flat
this is especially infinite universe if
I was on a 2d plane it would just look
like this and go on and on and on
forever and the third is if K is
negative and this is known as an open
universe which you can think of it's
it's it's a bit like a saddle and it's
also infinite so we have these three
types of universe all consistent and I'd
just wrap them all up in this general K
oh and by the way this term the K
doesn't appear in the acceleration
equation including the lambda term then
the acceleration equation now becomes
what it was before minus four PI G upon
three into Rho plus m3p over C squared
and then finally I ate this lambda term
is there it appears in this acceleration
now remember what I need what Albert
wanted was he wanted a dot and a double
dot to be zero so I just set the left
hand side of this equation and this
equation to be 0 so if I do it here
remember I'm saying that P equals zero
for because we're thinking of this is a
universe dominated by matter so not in
particular nonrelativistic matter like
like you are now made of so if I set a
double dot to be equal to zero
then I have a simple equation the threes
cancel and I have an equation for lambda
it just tells me that lambda is equal to
4pi G times the energy density in the
matter divided by C squared
if H you tunes lambda sitting exactly
matches the energy density then it will
give a universe that doesn't accelerate
what does it mean for the if you like
the velocity the Friedman equation so I
also need a dot to equal zero so I go
back to my Friedman equation and I
substitute in you can can you see that I
can substitute in for the lambda term
here replace the row with lambda and I
get the following expression 2 over 3
lambda C squared from for the from
Disick's from this term plus lambda C
squared upon 3 from that minus KC
squared over a squared equals 0 so I now
have a solution that tells me that
lambda minus K over s squared equals 0
and so that's telling me that a static
universe requires K which is equal to
lambda s squared to be positive because
lambda is positive the energy density is
positive so this must be positive so
this is telling me so Einstein for
Einsteins solution to work for him to
stop the universe from expanding he had
to make it a positively curved universe
with a cosmological constant
I think bread is going to stop me doing
any more maths but I've got one more
professor Copeland before we start at
said can I do equations
I'll just do two very simple one this is
what we're on so so I won't go into
three I won't go into the stability but
here's that here's the neat thing we've
got the universe which we've made it
static he did this in 1917 right as far
as I can tell it predated any of the
cosmology related papers which
demonstrated the universe was expanding
the the papers of I think the sitter may
have written one before that
but Lemaitre and Friedman they all came
later with their papers and yet they
were coming in saying there there are
all these other solutions which we're
not going to go into with but you we saw
it right at the beginning there if we if
we don't have that cause module cousin
and we don't have the curvature to
balance it then the universe will evolve
so there were all these evolving
universe solutions out there and he just
didn't like them he just said he
initially he thought there was some
mistakes made in some of the papers the
Friedman solution he thought was wrong
but then he realized it was right but he
said basically he said it's a correct
solution but I think it's just part of
your you know it's one of these with
wonderful solutions which this beautiful
system of equations has but is
irrelevant
Lemaitre had a solution which Einstein
said your solutions correct what your
physics is rubbish effectively and so he
just wouldn't buy it but you know at the
same time as all of this was happening
astronomers like slifer we're doing
observations of distant nebulae and they
were beginning to see evidence of the
light from these distant nebulae being
redshifted Einstein didn't accept this
as part of an evidence that the universe
must be doing something on these very
large scales then of course in the 20s
Hubble turned his attention to this and
he started looking at distant galaxies
and he realized the distant galaxies are
moving apart the a of T that we're
talking about here that these galaxies
are moving apart on very large scales
and he came up with this lor wishes that
basically the velocity of that they were
moving apart was proportion to their
separation so the further away they were
the faster they were moving after than
looking at the night sky hmm what was
Einstein basing this assumption on we
famously always get told never
to never assume anything for him the
underlying criteria which he was using
to sort of come up with that the thought
that the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic on those scales there's known
as Marx principle which was a principle
that sort of suggests that features on
large scales determine what we see on
small scales is one way of thinking
about it and on small scales we weren't
seeing anything evolving and so the
features on large scales shouldn't be
really evolving either I think that is
kind of where this came from I'm not
sure there's no value on the
cosmological constants not like it's not
like a pie or Hubble's calm it's not a
value that's coming out of some
fundamental theory which says yeah
lambda is equal to PI over a or
something but you can see from this
equation here when you mock my equations
but you know can now see that the lambda
depends upon whatever the density of
matter is in the universe so that's like
if you like an observational fact you
would measure that density that mean
density and you would set that would be
what you're learning that's another
cosmological constant won't come out as
eight yes maybe a number yeah and in
some units so you've got this solution
right now what you do in college when
you when you have a solution is you ask
one obvious question to ask about a
solution is is it stable right in other
words if I have a static solution here
for a what happens if I just hit it you
know is it with what just perturb it
with what well in this case what you're
perturbing is the density of the matter
you're letting the density of matter
vary ever so slightly so in a static
universe of course it's a constant
because it's not evolving but imagine I
just let it vary ever so slightly with
time so it's not it's a constant plus a
little bit and then you can ask well
what does that do to the evolution of
this scale factor does it somehow move
and yet then go back to its original
position so the static universe returns
that might be in the analog of a ball
going at the bottom of a colander right
if so it's stable points you think is at
the bottom and then you put you perturb
it slightly you push it up and then let
it go and then of course what happens is
it just oscillates slightly and goes to
the bottom
however on the other hand imagine that
you had a pencil and you were careful
enough that you could put the pencil
sharp end up and then you you know that
if I perturb that slightly just a little
it will go it will fall flat that's an
unstable situation and what really
surprised me it was that it wasn't until
1930 when Eddington published a paper he
said what happens if I perturb the
matter density ever so slightly what was
the consequence it has on this scale
factor and he found that a small
fluctuation in the matter caused the a
of T to act not to simply oscillate
around its fixed point and then come
back which is a stable search it either
grew exponentially fast or it decreased
exponentially fast it either went off to
infinity or shut down towards zero
you've got the evidence coming from
Hubble in 1920s from Slifer earlier that
the universe is exceeds to be expanding
Einstein didn't want to accept it you
then have Eddington showing that
Einsteins own solution is unstable and
then Einstein came and gave a lecture
here I don't think it was in German note
there's no record of the lecture except
we have that wonderful blackboard which
he signed on the 30th of June 1930 and
that would be still before Eddington
have managed to color in and bash him
into it saying actually your solutions
unstable yeah I just think it's nice
that within a few months of a weeks even
have been being here he was actually
beginning to accept the universe is
expanding but it is strange that it's
thirteen years after his original work
if I could conjure up Einstein and bring
him into the room now yes please
what would wold you ask him what would
you want to know or has science moved on
so much that he would be left behind now
he'd have to go and read a few books to
catch up on what's being built or he'd
have used to contribute if he'd be happy
to go back and think about gr there's so
much we've yet to really understand
about general ativy T there's a mass of
stuff that is yet to be uncovered as an
Einstein would be the guy to ask I'm
sure what he not doing at the time then
yeah because he died or you know no it's
a bit kind of a little bit sad in that
after the night that's in this 1931
paper he wrote on with the sitter was
his final paper in cosmology and I think
soon after that he began to
his attention turned to this idea of
unifying the forces and he that's where
he put cloud and most of his energies I
mean it must have been also the fact
that he was a major celebrity I mean
truly major celebrity right it was all
over the place sort of giving talks and
being invited to places but his own
research seemed to move into this area
of unifying the forces and and that as
it has with many people led him up dead
ends and and so I think it's fair circle
that there's not much of that work that
has survived today people don't refer to
much of that work he did some fantastic
things in the 30s on quantum mechanics
and that's but actually beginning to
come back is that people think about
things like quantum information but in
terms of gr in terms of those this
wonderful set of equations he kind of
left them for a while and never came
back to them and that's why I say if he
comes back and we could persuade him to
work on gr yeah it would be wonderful
very privileged to see this and to
realize that even famous scientists like
Einstein couldn't really use the
blackboard very clearly and so I might
have had difficulty to follow the
lecture